welcome back to cbs this morning we're
going to begin this hour with a major
development after the partial collapse
of that miami area condo tower
our miami station wfor reports that
rescuers pulled three more bodies from
the wreckage
bringing the death toll to four with
dozens still missing
crews from miami-dade fire rescue have
been digging through the rubble
for well over 24 hours now and our lead
national correspondent david begno
is in surfside where rain is once again
in the forecast david good morning to
you
tony good morning jimmy petronas is the
state fire marshal here
he's like the air traffic controller
overseeing the coordination effort
regarding the rain that has been falling
off and on it's a problem because it
adds more weight to the pile
explain the problem correct so we've had
fires through the night
those fires um have uh have to be
extinguished so we're
using fire hoses that adds weight you
can't we can turn off a fire hose
you can't turn off mother nature so the
men and women are
below ground working in a subterranean
parking garage
tunneling in in order to get to
survivors
so they're working in waste to chest
deep water
that also has fuel gasoline combustibles
because there's cars there they've been
compromised
and then when you have rain taking place
you just you add more and at the same
time
water is being pumped out so because the
garage is essentially underwater it's
underwater
below sea level correct so it's it's
it's below sea level
it's holding water it's like a big
underground swimming pool as you're
pumping water out
those men and women are working with
with heavy equipment
labor intensive to try to tunnel jimmy
people at home might be wondering why
not
why not come from the top right just
start pulling the rocks back and dig
below
you you can't go that way because of you
create further collapse
so they go in they tunnel in where they
they can short up
the structural engineers that are
embedded with this team there's
surgeons that are embedded in this team
and that whole
effort together as soon as they're there
at a moment's notice because sometimes
when they find somebody you have to save
their life right then and there
i i think about those guys underground
is that not dangerous for them i mean
what if the rest of the building
collapses so
you'll see that the building the
building is is incredibly compromised
right now uh there's structural
challenges all to the building
you only can inspect it so much because
if you're going to wait
people's lives are lost so the men are
working
as at the same time they're putting out
fires at the same time
the building can fall but not fully
extinguishing the fires because the tens
of thousands of gallons of water they
have to extinguish the fire with
they don't want to put it out so they're
just kind of nursing it it's just
changing the equilibrium exactly just
get it to where it's manageable
and then if it stops smoking they've won
and then they continue but then you know
what the fire comes back
so they're they they'll try to use fire
hoses as little as possible right now
those guys are heroes but you know they
are
they are they are thank you jimmy thanks
david back to you
david thank you very much